yes politico lo vedo il quality
contenute in questo momento lo vedo e lì
allora bene tutti ragazzi bevete questo
video sono fa vj e ci siano sugo blick
che sarebbe spiegabile istruzione ma io
ho un tentacolo ai labour sulu va bene
ok ragazzi vi riassumo quello che ha
detto la tizia siamo sul gol i corpi che
sarebbe sto gioco che tipo octo dead
solo che è un po strano perché successo
tentacolo che è tra l'altro è un
tentacolo italiano perché così niente io
sono look to you e devo fare cose e
karin c'è sembra carino poi non lo so
comunque schiacciamo il pulsante come si
schiaccia il bus come lo schiaccio ha
così va bene aiuto cosa devo fare
antartico fare qui
io devo fare le cose dice questo mondo e
devo fare delle cose va bene va bene
però non mi spiegate cosa devo fare nel
gioco io credo che come te ne so allora
questa è una levetta la premiata pero il
quadro dietro era bellissimo va bene
allora ci sono degli insetti che io devo
schiacciare allora questa cosa l'ho
capita
non ho capito in che modo a popoli di
tiro via li mortacci tua
questa roba mi sta piacendo quindi devo
resistere ma giuro non ho capito devo
mandare via perché alla fine io volevo
riassumervi il tutorial ma non ho capito
una sega che c'è un insetto c'è un
insetto via via tutti cosa devo fare qua
spiegate vino non so niente non capisco
non ho capito io vi giuro non ho capito
questo sto facendo dello giorno non so
cosa sto facendo
devo sto sparando via degli insetti e
sto cambiando la posizione del mondo
qualcuno mi spiega perchè non mi
spiegano a me lo fa fare il suo gioco
dirmi cosa devo fare non lo so devo
cambiare la posizione del ma cosa vuol
dire cosa vuole di do not play orca
vaccamorta cosa devo scaldare con la
lampada tipo
e quello che devo fare dillo ok allora
l'antartico lo scaldata manca al sud
america che non son riuscito a farlo ho
perso faccio schifo
devo scaldare i posti con la lampada
quello devo fare cosa vi siete formati
per fa sta roba sud america asia
antartica ho chiamato da questa al sud
america oggi impariamo la geografia per
per to look e allora scaldiamo sud
america questa el'antartide pica
ecco quindi devo scaldare le col
antartica se la scavi non è proprio il
massimo però contro le leggi del mondo
va bene l'idolo scaldare i posti niente
l'ho semplicemente scaldare i posti
nella mente che butto via insetti mi
sembra la trama più bella mai vista per
un videogioco pensare che molti
aspettano del nostro fase due la siete
scemi
devo cambiare la radio station va bene
mettiamo radio maria radio cutulo anzi
radio tutto cambiato
ti piace sta radio fa una più cagare
l'altro la radio fottuti insetti via
no no no gli insetti non ho capito se ti
fanno male se arrivano se arrivano sul
mondo forse fanno male però non lo
scopriamo lo via via via che male non si
toglie tentando di togliere non si
toglie perché schifo ho perso ma no ma
dai ma basta riesco a fare neanche il
tutorial
no no no no no via l'ho tirato
fortissimo che male gli ho fatto allora
amici miei e non è così difficile se
riesco a risi la prima primo tentativo è
andato molto più vicino anche perché una
certa sono spuntati 8.000 insetti ci sto
giocando a calcio così come va via a
guardà tempo che sono un off to look
contro l'eni se ti schifosi non riesco a
farcela tratto se tocco il monitor
appare l'errore di windows simpatico
occhio che qua ci sono un miliardo sia
perfetto no via
che schifo una volta mi sono trovato uno
nel letto di sti cosa ci ha fatto con il
video poroso schifo via via via vieri
aspetta che mi sto dimenticando di di
girare sti affari
aspetta che fiorì se va via button è il
punto ho fatto tanto quando completi
livello ce lo stesso rumore di
infarinate freddy's come se fossero
prove mi hanno dato una valutazione che
fa schifo però va bene un importante
aver passato il livello aspetta che sta
arriva grazie molto gentile c'è uno
spray lo spray a cosa serve io devo di
dare vita agli alberi nel mentre che
combatto gli insetti molto chiaro
partiamo che sono vai vai vai tranquillo
anno mi devono morire tutti molto chiaro
si ok ok mi perdono proprio le cose figo
va bene ci sono insetti anche in questo
livello ma è tra l'altro perché sono un
buio un of two lui come vi spiego cosa
no tu lo sa chi non conosce il look to
you not too low e tipo vostra zia quando
si sveglia la mano di prigione cose che
devo fare io qua come lo show down che
panic passaquindici come lo si sa chi
come cosa devo fare
oh mio dio oh mio dio mi ha dato una
seriamente oddio ma non fv riferendo di
allora sto gioco prima lo era cosa da
fare cos'è ragazzi sta succedendo della
roba un mio dio sia aperto il muro e
quindi si sta aprendo quindi cosa devo
fare lo spara qualcuno aveva anche gioco
fighissimo è sto male lo sparare a della
gente
chi è quello l'ho colpito non è morto e
non muore
mani sto male io devo fare questa cosa e
nel mentre annaffiare le piante pure
perché mi stava schiatta mi è caduto il
cosa perché l'inter consolida meno mi è
caduta parola pistola avete avuto tutto
sono scemo è difficilissimo regate
stanno a schiatta agli alberi gli alberi
gli alberi prendili prendili aspetto
aspetta e non si pigliano ok perfetto
aspetta che c'è un tia devo riprendere
gli alberi un attimo che casino ma che
chi senso a cosa sto giocando di va bene
l'importante che non schiattino gli
alberi sono perdo la partita quanto dura
sta roba
in teoria dovrei dovrei avere così
finito in teoria molto bene ho ripreso
tutti gli alberi bravissimo la pistola
sta qua caro tanto possono colpire la
radio da dietro fighissimo va bene per
adesso sono stato molto bravo
ho finito le vere complete e stato bello
è bellissimo c'è non è della stoffa però
the last of cthulhu ma ancora quanti
punti bebè verde verde la performance ex
l nel rosso sempre ma excelent quindi va
bene bene e verrai slight porca vacca
devo fare tutte ste robe devo anche
volare nel mentre questo potrebbe essere
un problema
avevo mettere i pezzi di pianeta al suo
posto giusto
ok però c'è la gravità pure frutti di
casino sì ma se mi mollano le robe
davanti non vedo niente e io devo
proteggere anche il mio pianeta dai
meteoriti quindi a tempo perso da
schiacciare pure il tasto qua aspetto
che ho visto il per questo pezzo come
questo voglio in mano questo qua questo
compendio premio premio che metti la
metti lo è ma devo girarlo macello rega
ma non saprò mai quattro minuti per
vince ma è impossibile ma devo ma devo
essere un non posso mai farcela ma non
arrivano i meteoriti sul pianeta nostro
sé che problemi hai spiegami alla colla
la cosa c'è scritta di la colla prendi
la colla prendi la colla la metto
possono pre lametta possa fornire
l'omessa ora vuoi che io metta un altro
pezzo sopra va bene molto chiaro
mettiamo un altro pezzo sopra non è
questo via
sembra questo qui eccolo qua o tre
martellate qualora nuova della madonna
nel mentre dovrebbero arrivare dei
meteoriti anzi si sta arrivando scritto
l'inizio intanto martello come se non ci
fosse un porca vacca a quello non era il
timer perché prima che arrivasse
meteorite con la realtà ymer per farlo
schiantare erano chiede di liste gol che
ne so io
va bene allora rifacciamo il pezzo la
colla la coop
la colla ok metti la colla ti porta
sacro e smettila colla qua perché ok via
devo mettere pezzo qua 3 martellate e
non vedo niente se continua la roba
davanti non vedo che spara spara spara
su famiglia sparare poi in mente i pezzi
giusto sparando dovrei levarli di mezzi
meteoriti sparando è stato fatto
martellare martelliamo marte il martello
il martello prendi lo prendi lo non
riesco a prendere ok della colla è
impossibile costruire tutto e lo dico
lega schiaccia ma perché devi fare il
giro del tasto ma tre schiaccianti
quanti problemi perché c'è un cubo di
rubik come potrei mai fare un cubo di
rubik sono snob tulu il polipo gigante o
il tentacolo grazie
mancavano 15 secondi tra l'altro come ok
dover concludere che ansia
va bene ho fatto in tempo è stato bello
mi sento il salvatore del mondo excel
ent qualcuno ha detto excel ed excel
così in inglese grazie amico mio hai
ragazzi sembra vi sia piaciuto cosa che
ci piace tutto vi piace sono stati
fischiati e noi ci rivediamo come al
solito proseguito la ragazza
[Musica]